okay for people joining this livestream
this is a continuing discussion about
how to handle historical geography so
let's recall what we did last time
handling polygons and data intervals in
time series okay okay can somebody
summarize what we concluded about each
of these things with a time series with
timestamps and hold from left for now we
don't have a way to a policy until when
that that is valid and the workaround is
to Adam I last missing value okay but
what the plan for that is that we are
introducing a what is the plan for that
can you remind me please
can you remind me we discussed this last
time about my project managing here I am
Ben H ok can you remind me where where I
put my notes please let me check my
notes from last time ok because that's
kind of what we need when we're going to
do one of these meetings I don't want to
be repeating myself ok I pulled it up
myself thank you
ok alright I got it now so you don't
need to do anything here um could you
put yourself on mute so we're not
hearing grinding noise um
okay so can you remind me what we had
concluded about dates pans and so on
we had a new construct as I recall that
represents the thing we need for this
this historical country case correct yes
as a proposal one of the strongest
proposals was to absolutely have these
date intervals as let's say left-hand
side of the time serious well right okay
fine then that's what we should plan on
doing so that the time series group
knows that and that's a project that
we're going to proceed on right that
correct hey come on okay but I mean we
need to come up with conclusions in
these meetings we're not just doing this
for the sake of discussing things right
so that was a conclusion from last time
and Ben can you please write a summary
of these and send it out to everybody
yes I can do that okay
and make sure we have one from so we
don't seem to have that from last time
that's what I would have expected to see
in the notebook this time okay
understood
hmm okay okay what did we think we
solved him what did we do him
not only that we decided to actually use
the largest polygon for you don't
specify any NATO's fine okay all right
using data intervals are all in
Geographics okay so this was the thing
where we were going to use different
opacity levels correct right
okay seems kind of cool um
but I think people are gonna want that
that was another thing we discussed
right what happened with that discussion
of being able to list things
um
this is some kind of weighted
Geographics where you could in principle
list something it's similar to geo
region value plot if I'm not mistaken
right but where you are you're waiting
particular polygons right
do you remember what I'm talking about
we gave a light last time
yes I was having some kind of borders
inside there but I think this is a
simpler proposal of having actually
treaties dated all which will return me
mentally I think serious treat that list
of all the values and this is what will
happen to them then Geographics of a
time series is going to do what it's
going to extract all the all the values
from the time series and put them we're
waiting mechanism okay there is no need
to wait in Meganium because right now it
already has some opacity so it's like
complicities no no no I understand but
if the time interval was it lasted for a
thousand years in this form and then
there was five years in this form you
obviously want to wait two thousand year
one oh I see to split the opacity such
way that we waited yes that's right
right does that make sense now if a
bunch of Geographics it's interpreted as
a list of notes okay well I think that's
wrong yeah it's yes I mean I think we
independent of Geographics we might want
to do that for other purposes - I mean I
don't even know you know should we have
some version of graphics or something
that does that am I making sense okay so
the issue there is time series of
polygons no graphics of time series of
polygons making sense
so I don't know
graphics I mean other than straight
graphics what else would we expect to
have work in a certain way so for
example if I say you know if I were to
say list plot of a time series what
could I what should I expect to happen
there I mean it's you know one might be
led to think that graphics of a time
series might produce things of different
densities what is the mechanism for
doing that it's difficult to represent a
flow of time to know what it's very
difficult I don't think that's I mean
and then this way of doing it but what
I'm saying is in addition to Geographics
don't we want to be able to have this
capability that is a time series where
the I mean you know a time series of
polygons or a time series of graphics
objects I mean or more generally um
time series of graphics objects yes
which we don't have any notes about do
we have notes from the previous meeting
yes I have the notes I took in the last
meeting and sent out to everyone else in
this meeting I can forward them to you
if you'd like please do that yes that's
what we generally should start from in
these meetings okay go ahead because I
wonder what we will need is a way to
convert these time series of you wait at
least you know that will be used by any
other function yes well that would be a
reasonable general way to do it
okay so hold on let's let's um let's
talk about essentially what we're
talking about is
gyeo dateless plot 3d or something
that's the thing that will generate the
world tube I will use the 3d because
that sounds like we are going to do a
blob - dirty - what do I look
I know but usually things which produce
3d output and in 3d right ok but so now
what you're suggesting is general way of
converting time-series to weighted lists
so in other words we have a particular
value so what how would you do that go
sure right now if I make a time series
and I say well I see right right now we
don't really have I mean we could have a
hold from left version of this am I
making sense
but did you understand what I'm saying
go sure all kind of and so you could
look at the time stamps take the
difference and then that gonna give you
the intervals between the you know that
yes
convert that to you know to the to the
rules with the values in that way what
she's now doing it's the another way to
create time series from the assignments
so it's no but what I'm saying we get
how do we get a histogram how do we get
I mean so if I say histogram of this
right I will get those values right you
need to date histogram if we have dates
for example this is updates but I'm what
I'm saying is what we're doing here is
we're getting the the to look if I do
here seventy arrow ten okay yeah I don't
understand this at all I do understand
this little I mean this is saying that
that can you add another repeated value
because what it does it takes the
histogram on the values so if you do for
example I don't know four goes to ten
okay but that's that's not doing what I
wanted it to do at all okay fine but
what I want this to do is I want to find
out this time series if I do a dateless
plot of that time series right oh wow
that's really funky okay okay okay I
understand that that makes some sense
okay so what I want to know is weighted
by how long I'm in each state what is
the probability distribution of the
values Jen someone I'm saying right yes
yeah I know you you're different
frequency
but I mean so if I were to do this as
date intervals here or a hold from left
time series right what I would want is
that the 10 here or whatever it is I
don't know how the time series is
working but it goes up to okay so by the
time it's so the value 10 will have a
much higher probability than these other
values making sense
yes because that's what we're trying to
do here what we're doing here is we're
showing a density we're showing a
distribution you know we're showing in
opacity the probability that this
particular point is in the set am I
making sense so here what we want is the
probability distribution of values
weighted by how long that value was
persisting in the time series right
mm-hmm so how do we do that I think we
need we're going to need something to do
that because otherwise we're gonna have
this really weird singular case of the
Geographics situation that's different
from these other ones right yeah I mean
you understand yeah I'm thinking okay
all right I'm just I see a problem I'm
just thinking of ways of resolving that
well there's something of that sort
already exists yeah III that's what I
was wondering too all right so let's
keep go ahead yes I put in the chatter
so that the times it could be converted
into these weighted data
proper that we really have two example
and they're the problem will be their
right hand limit for example something
like that is that even mean so the
weighted data is the values and the
weight for each oh you mean the whole
thing yeah I get it I get it I go yes
yes yes yes yes I agree that's what
that's a reasonable thing to imagine
doing the
what is that what is this actually mean
with weighted data their values and then
the weights so these are the weights
yeah okay the differences between the
timestamps yes right right I mean this
is a distribution of values so what is
the thing that normally would give a
distribution of values it's essentially
bin counts isn't it for a generic if I'm
not mistaken or what what is it I mean
it's this is giving the probability that
but it's gonna it's gonna so it's gonna
give you according to the beans so you
gonna have this partition yeah which is
horrible so what you actually want is
right here okay
so here there are two spaces where you
know there's the sort of vertical that
there's the color space which is the
value of this probability distribution
and then there's the sort of base space
which is the graphics here right so what
I could imagine is a time series I mean
I could imagine another case and maybe
this is even more general than time
series I don't know but I think it
particularly applies to time series so
if I say 2 comma 5 you know 6 comma 4
whatever then eventually then what I
could do is I could say as a function of
this value I want to know the
distribution of this value south on the
live stream is commenting on empirical
distribution but I don't think that
quite does what we want does it but it
kind of does I'm just looking at that
chill so or you can apply this to time
series what does it do
that's interesting okay so if I say you
can do plot of the CDF of that why am i
doing CDF why isn't the PDF because it's
point it only yes the jumps so the PDF
would be just almost to be 0 almost
everywhere an axe call say from X to 70
is 0 to 70 ok I think that's more or
less what we want isn't it mm-hmm
ok well that's very good now does it do
the right thing here with respect to the
holes from left business and so on or is
it assuming it's obviously not assuming
so this picture has very you know
interpolated variation from one time to
the next but this picture assumes there
is no interpolation correct because it's
on the values no but the look look but
the values here there are intermediate
values shown in that plot I don't think
this is consistent all right let's not
get stuck on this for right now that we
should think about that but this this
overall behavior looks fairly sensible
to me
so just to comment the city of there he
just assumes it's piecewise constant
well in a day least thought it actually
thoughts points and then connects them
so you can I search a sign I search
you're saying that the mission is
different you you plot the piecewise
function and so it knows you just give
you the the flood into you know
intervals fair enough fair enough
all right so what you're claiming is
that this empirical distribution thing
will more or less give us what we want
here so how does empirical distribution
relate to the Roman Empire here so if
I'm saying if I've got a time series of
polygons for the Roman Empire and I say
empirical distribution of that what on
earth am I getting I mean what it should
be giving me is
the
you
what what should it be I mean one thing
it could give me is the
length of time that a point on the earth
was in the Roman Empire the distribution
of lengths of time that a point on the
earth was in the Roman Empire
right Amaya correct right that's the
analog here yes is that correct or am I
missing something that's the analog of
this case that's giving me the empirical
distribution of the values in this time
series weighted by how long that value
was maintained yes correct so here this
should give me for every geopoint
which is the analog of a value here it
should give me the distribution of the
length of time you know that that that
point was in the Roman Empire is that
true like that but I'm not sure that
will be directly taken from that because
what we have as values are the polios so
we will test in which of these polygons
this point was for example and see then
so I mean the values are not exactly the
points of this I mean this is like a
bivariate distribution where as a
function of lat/long just like if I have
a bivariate Gaussian or something I mean
in other words one question would be if
I were to compare the okay so here is a
typical type of thing how similar is the
[Music]
you know growth of the Roman Empire to a
Gaussian or something to a you know so
that's a question that we should be able
to answer because we should be able to
have an empirical distribution I assume
that in spatial statistics you will be
able to do that but then we've got to
compare did you get what I'm saying
so right now I am feeling a that we
could confusing time and space so one
thing is you cross-section for a given
point and you can ask the question in
time right and then for example we could
ask the question you know if this point
belongs to their dated
polygon of the Roman Empire you'll have
it for a given point and then for the
for the special case it is you know it's
slightly different problem
because if you have a given point you
may ask if the point nearby you know
what's the probability for a point
nearby to also belong to the Roman
Empire okay those are different
questions I agree there are different
questions and but what I'm saying is
that look time compressing time to get a
just a probability is one thing okay
you're discussing also the purely
special case but compressing time to get
a probability like for instance you know
it could be that you know from Rome as a
center that isn't obvious it doesn't
look like it's the case but from Rome as
a center that the distribution of times
that a given place spent in the Roman
Empire was roughly Gaussian distributed
with Rome as a center for example
obviously not true based on what what we
see here but but that's something you
could imagine being the case where
probability is determined by what
fraction of the time you get what I'm
saying yes but that's what we talk about
the points so even for a given space
location you could figure out you know
in the given time frame with probability
that the point was in the Roman Empire
based on how long given point was
exactly yes yes but I'm just saying how
would we actually do that because anyway
that point will be split along different
polygons of course of this time series
yes you are converting somehow there yes
I know look I'm trying to get this
function okay you've got a nice picture
here okay another way to put it is
you've got a nice picture here but what
if I actually want to compute this
function for I want to know what is this
value for you know for Edinburgh okay
yeah so that's another question right is
what is the length of time Edinburgh
which I probably can't even spell um oh
my gosh it doesn't have the first pieces
in there um was in the Roman Empire
right how would you answer that question
or what is the time interval what are
the time intervals date intervals in
which it is included I'm asking I'm
thinking that in the same way that we
have a Geo group I wonder whether we
could have some sort of time group in
which you have the polygons and then we
can ask this sort of question what is
the trail group what do you mean a trail
group geo group is what we use in order
to it's a bit like a geo Union the union
of we can use entities or directly the
polygons themselves and then we will put
them together and the area would be the
sum of the areas I don't remember this
when did we put the Sun to be document
this sure since the very beginning of
success yes because we created that even
before entity group so that's why
because we needed that okay so if I
would say then geo group of hello can
you hear me yes sure what cheer group of
NYC LA
so I could say that population that
correct treat multiple geo objects as a
single group for purposes of computation
so why doesn't that work I figure
computation so far what it's graphically
computation geographical so your group
it's not you are using entity value here
so your group is understood by I wonder
whether entity group would work there
yes beautifully so why do we need a geo
group different from entity group well
it existed first and then entity group
is not for example entity group would
not accept two polygons well your group
does what would that just do it's
computing the minimal distance from
London to those two are same so your
computation treats them as the Union
that's the point and you can also put
explicit polygons there which is they
are fair enough okay so what are you
suggesting I was I I was trying to find
that time in the same way that this geo
group is spatial joining I was trying to
find some sort of temporal joining of
things so that they form a single unity
you know yeah okay all right but I mean
this type of question to show what are
the data intervals in which I mean what
would we think that how would we think
that would look so first question is
okay first question is is something
let's take Roman Empire as a as a as a
thing and now I want to know is
Edinburgh in the Roman Empire how do I
find that out
co-member what is what is the
appropriate thing to ask if something is
in this you only think you I'm sorry
yeah we thank you thank you
okay so geo with NQ then of this comma
Los Angeles but a good false what okay
what's all this is about adding the
support for in do we think you on all
functions to the historical volume right
now we've got okay fair enough
all right okay fine so that should work
okay so then the question is what is the
time series analog of geo within cue
right and we almost want something which
is almost like
I'm this is I'm making this up in a very
weird way but let's imagine it was um
something like this oops by the way this
is question is exactly what we are
adding in the notebook as next section
okay fine all right okay but but you did
you get the idea of something like this
right so you could do this because that
the Roman Empire if that comes is a time
serious right he could we could go over
all the polygons
well did you yes that could be mobbed
that way I mean this syntax is incorrect
but yeah I understand okay so that you
input a time series or a dated all
related and a date interval that will be
converted into the time series and then
we will output that experience that base
that's propulsion okay so hold on let's
look at that okay oh wow good good for
you okay is this work right now oh I see
it does we're done right good I agree
that's exactly how that should work
yes I think that's right
I mean I'm a little concerned about
whether everything needs should have the
same default polygon cheer within queue
probably
yeah I feel like we should use the same
default most extended polygons all the
cases me that's that would be more
uniform and and maybe use the dated
although some kind of dated Union maybe
two specified in the whole Union and
that's where Jose was proposing Native
American rapper to have this time group
instead of date advice yes I think this
is crazy I mean I think this is this is
really weird to have a cue function
return a time series
although we are painting ourselves into
a bit a little bit into that corner
right because somehow the cube functions
are ready to returns at least so the
time series will be this extended list
when does the cube function return the
list
well do we think you returns are at
least when you confer lists because it
works like an outer
very good idea well we wanted your
waiting queue to be leased out that's
the point so so we're greater you're
willing you to be least arguable it
shouldn't have had a queue at the end
[Music]
maybe we should have a version of it
without the queue at the end I think I'm
just saying something like even queue
listed really you are correct
okay well then yeah I think we follow
with that okay okay okay fair enough
okay well if that's the case then then I
agree that this isn't so crazy
well what's this I see that's the within
enos of that with two moving targets
right that will be like the intersection
of all the date there was created
through force of these intersections
right so that could be an interpretation
that's what we are asking here that
since
so
but in this case I mean so it'll be some
kind of hold from left time series so
that if you say
so we're if I want to index into a time
series and find out the value for a
specific of a specific time what do I do
go sure
can I just do this and then index into
that not index forgives a date um let's
say I say Jan 1st 1950 1948 okay why
does it do that as a date object why
doesn't it display with a date format
that's another separate bug is Nick here
he's out today
can you please communicate that to him
yep okay so this is okay so that's what
that that works right applying time
series to a date will give the value add
that page yes okay um makes me wonder
why a power series like this doesn't do
that as well
maybe I'm just crazy but why wouldn't
this it's kind of crazy I suppose is
that crazy to have that work maybe it's
just crazy
I mean parser is a very old function
before we were really doing currying and
things okay okay that's a separate thing
maybe you could ask Roger about that go
show maybe that's for you
okay um it just doesn't seem to me that
it's sort of define as a function well
most time series in which one plus X
plus X no no no no time series why is
that a function either yet it is
applicable to a particular value a
particular x value and returns a value
see what I'm saying well it's an object
anyway so so we can add them up values
and see there were so is this an object
actually it's a serious data object okay
well maybe
okay let's this okay put that in ILD
we'll discuss it there okay then can you
make sure that gets communicated yes
okay okay now let's come back to this so
that's for within cubit to asking this
question how long
has a given point what is the time
series
oh I see this is the time series of
trues and falses but now if I want to
ask what is the duration in that time
series right so that appears to be a
time series of trues and falses is that
correct yeah and then to do a duration
of two we will need these weighted 8000
like that it was true false well but
actually isn't it the case that just
saying empirical distribution of this
should give that result but that doesn't
show me that's the distribution as
opposed to showing me
for each I'm so confused here for each
for true and for false what is their
duration in here and yeah I wonder for
that case weighted data will be better
because that's exactly that for each
value how much of that lighting I'm also
wondering if curation could have a
second argument
doesn't duration work yeah it does work
on time series what about having a
second argument for duration oh sure I
don't know this is not my design so I
cannot comment okay that's gonna be the
audio and signal processing team okay
well why don't you ask them
Oh what do you what would you want in
the in the second thing for example I
could say duration of in this time
series instead of that time whole time
series so if I say duration of that
whole time series I'm going to get kind
of crazy the unit's there are kind of
crazy but anyway never mind okay so now
if I say that comma true right then I
want to get is the duration of true that
time series but now what I also might
want is something like how long has that
time series been between minus 6 and 6
but it is like count yeah yeah maybe
we'll have a different function for
these because the duration will be the
right hand side will be very will need
to be very flexible well not if it's
just counting the amount of time so that
that you know the two things okay I
don't think it's completely stupid for
them you could say how long has some
some frequency yeah yeah I would think
so to what
what duration is the sound level above
such-and-such now I admit I'm not sure
this is quite the probably the design is
not quite right but something like that
um we have a comment from Brian on the
live stream let's see polygons got a
list of date ranges how much of the
polygon was in the date ranges
subdivision of the polygon until a
specified percentage was in the Roman
Empire oh boy
I don't think we can get a confidence
for
each interval because I think that these
the state this is not a kind of data
where we can give any reasonable error
bounds it's like three historical
atlases said this but you know Herodotus
said that I mean it's hard to it's just
hard to know
Caesar claimed that he'd catch
part of Gaul but actually everybody said
he was you know what would we give us
the as the confidence for that um
okay that looks beautiful is there a
problem of this
like a good thing to do here
nations from the Year 1500 located
within that territory that looks well
that's interesting
gon today's that's interesting yeah okay
I would say yes by default by default
that should include him Shh
roof roof yeah I mean yes because each
of these military conflicts has a point
in time mountains don't have a point in
time they don't have a point in space
make sense
now for all these things that are
quarries with later do we return dated
objects as well what you mean the fact
that we are inserting the date in the
input I wonder whether we should
propagate it to the output because
presumably the objects are also temporal
objects I switcher sang so in other
words if you say dated historical
country in 1500 should we return England
than 1500 with a dated rapper
as opposed to just returning England
yeah I think the answer is yes in that
case in the case where there's a
right-hand side here that has a second
argument with dated I kind of agree with
you that that represents we are asking
for the 1500 dated historical country
whereas in this case we're not asking
for that but what if the dated there see
a military conflict as a point in time a
historical country is not right in a
sense it's like inserting data of the
entity type accommodate in the first
argument of entity which should
propagate the data topside yeah actually
let me correct that on nostri conflict I
mean the hundred years war presumably
one could say this particular time in
the Hundred Years War although I'm not
sure we could do with that did you see
what I'm saying well I think that we
only add the dated when they input the
dated yeah fair enough
but but nevertheless in this case we
would say we will only the Geo entities
see for example for example for example
let me give you another example okay so
um comets visible during the Roman
Republic okay how would we figure that
out
so that is an analog of Geo entities but
for time so I'm saying but in this case
probably the Comets will have the date
information themselves so I mean my
whole point is that that is during the
time span of the Roman Republic
what comets were visible so in that
that's potentially a different thing
like for example if I want to know yeah
here's a question for our if I want to
know what spacecraft were launched in
1961 how do I do that if I say
spacecraft that's not encouraging why
doesn't that work so that would turn
into an entity class of spacecraft well
let's say satellites for now and then
that would say launch date why that
isn't daughter of completing I have no
idea can you please report that burn yes
and then let's say year 1961 isn't there
property there should be that would be a
data query parse um I'll look at that
okay
so there's that so question is why
doesn't this work so I mean this whole
class of things should be working
oh I see what you're saying
oh my gosh maybe it worked is that what
you're saying maybe that actually worked
perhaps no way no way well I mean let's
try if we really wonder about that we
can try Oh perhaps it's because the
dates are giving to the second and it's
exactly exactly looking for the date
well so win it then then how do we
specify that that's supposed to be an
interval yeah I think that this is I
think what's happened here is that the
the way that this date property has got
its value specified is wrong because
we're not dealing with date
granularities properly here okay okay
well that's fairly civilized for that
okgo identify and what is this not yes
but what I wanted to say is that I'm not
always sure that we shall have this by
default because how will you specify
that you don't want this time
correlation between the target and the
source what
so how will you specify I want all the
military confident using dated military
conflict all I mean this is gonna get
quite weird I mean if you say this
column eletric conflict and then you end
up getting things in the Second World
War
it's going to seem wrong well okay so
okay so my question is and how will you
decide the other way because it's easier
all military conflicts through history
that occurred there I think you'd say
date at all okay not that signs that no
I think I think that's right okay
to identify who somebody's typing an
area um
okay why isn't this returning a time
series
you
that's a mess
I think it should return a time-series
because do you identify normally okay so
if I would have said you identify here
just country come around
Cicely
I'm confused why this doesn't return
time series in this case
what's this thing so he identified
returns the a list of entities that are
in that place that's it and you can also
specify more elements in the first
argument so you could put let's say you
could put country alternative and mister
deviation itself so we shouldn't also
consider that the case that we are
missing stuff sometimes we can mix
parrot what's it called
no it's arguably by the way that Aramis
should be better okay so that way you
also so if you specifically country
would return the date that the entity
Instax can you do with it
those dated things let's say that I
wanted to plot what would I want to do I
want to give I mean if I give this right
I doubt that this could be successfully
used in timeline plot there may be even
a problem in the sense that if some
functions are already written in time
serious for historical entity types
perhaps we cannot mix the historical
entity types with their okay should this
have given should this of given a I mean
whatever this returns should be able to
be fed to timeline plot should knit I
mean just like at the top here these
time series that we were dealing with
right
I should presumably be able to feed that
to Timeline plot it's a little funky but
it's not obviously crazy right okay so
what format does this need to be in so
that I could feed it to turn line plot
and by the way what happens if I do this
if I say time series of this and feed
that time line plot ouch is that really
right again
okay look geo identify should be
returning something that can be fed to
time line plot shouldn't it I'm not sure
because you know that's a more generic
function but my point you will mix that
different types so what then it would
give then it should give a time line
plot of all of those things I'm just
saying whatever format this is better be
accepted by time line plot but I know
and understand why it isn't a time
series or possibly multiple time series
if it's if it's also well I know I don't
know why it isn't a time series possibly
with the overlapping intervals I don't
think we have I thought we were thought
it was the whole point of temporal data
gosho can you speak to that no over up
so the assumption is that you don't have
multiple values on the same timestamp so
no you can't because you have ambiguity
what what does really happen on what
happens in temporal data doesn't it do
that temporal data you could give
different paths so it means that you
could have you know more you have a
different path and then well it's the
same timestamp no that time sums can be
different for these four
puffs the only donut limitation is that
you deal with the same dimensionality of
the values but I can give different time
different time stamps for each path in
temporal data okay
but so why isn't that doesn't that
achieve this why isn't that the same
thing as this let's have a quick look at
the other issues here okay so I mean
something has to be solved here I don't
think this is right
again I'm gonna say it again how would
you use this output
well so the other was to me and
equivalent to entity instance but we
dated which is the key event or anything
sense with dates a do it I say okay well
maybe we should just make timeline plot
except that
you
because because what's happening here
oh I see no no go ahead go go what are
you saying right because lady is that
dated will be it's a really accepted by
for example line your graphics or by
other functions or it's alright okay
you're beginning to convince me so it's
like entity instance then and in fact
probably is equivalent to an entity
instance I I sing under
okay all right okay well again again I'm
gonna say it again time line plot would
need to support this then does that make
sense to everybody
yeah sorry I don't know if that supports
our rate for example entity instance we
paid probably also be done but that
seems fairly straightforward what if you
returned association doesn't seem like a
good idea this seems like a better idea
because this these each element here is
semantically meaningful decision
interval goes to one kingdom so that's
very similar what you were put inside a
time series yes well that that actually
works with a time line plot fine but
doesn't matter we could get this to work
with time line plot because as you say
no in fact that won't work as an
association won't work because those
intervals could be the same right all
right let's keep going here I think I
I'm now convinced that what you have
there is reasonable
um okay identify the historical country
in which the Pyramid of the Sun was
built
you
okay so when it was finished
geo identify okay
what the heck is this what is this
so right now to get this that other
result that is the proposed syntax we
will need to do these things that's what
we are working proposing now it seems
very very sensible to me I mean
in general this could be a time range
here
right this could be a place with a time
range and there could be multiple
okay explain to me why this isn't
returning teo is that a is that a
Peruvian Empire
well whatever how well you say that
anyway yo T what can this um Oh Mexico
okay
the UM all right the in a case this this
something maybe we should return also
dated here that's that's what I'm saying
yeah yeah a standard think we have to do
that yeah
so it would appear that that existed on
that specific date we're gonna end up
needing a function that strips the dated
now I think if historical country was
wrapped in dated no I don't think that's
right because the convention up here was
if there if the second argument has a
dated thing around it the argument in
defines your entities are flipped I see
I see I see okay all right okay okay you
convinced me okay
buildings and historical sites built in
the Roman Empire
don't have any more than that that's
really weird that's so phew
don't you think
that's really weird
it seems enhancing I think that's
because that's only the Roman Republic
how okay
well that looks highly sensible to me
you
you
yes missing don't it doesn't exist as
what I think it should do
but this by the time you at
evaluated position that is just to cheer
position right so it no longer knows
that had anything to do with a
particular date right lost any right so
I think that that first thing is correct
there I think the second thing should
say you know missing didn't exist
basically
I will probably need a a particular tag
for the missing to represent this
that makes sense
and I'm saying missing not in existence
what's that well if you've got a better
suggestion we shall think about that we
have discussed in the past Robin dated
around the opposition which would mean
inserting the date inside that your
position so that's a possibility
propagating the dates
yeah but not in this case because this
case the thing just didn't exist period
end of story
yeah but the problem was I think in the
first florence cathedral position is
that you know sorry it's a time interval
and your position right now who doesn't
cannot be filled with a time interval
and so i thought very existence exists
waiting on waiting but if that was your
1500 for the second case yes that will
be and that's where we should return the
missing when we see that that date is
out of the valley big interval that's an
interesting function this thing here
I don't like really the word event
it's not really an event I mean this
isn't
you
yes so here we started really different
discussions how to treat lookups dates
well this is very interesting this this
is clearly a good idea to be able to say
I mean I would have thought the more
natural thing would be to say so they're
two issues there's time and space here
identify things of a particular category
right so geo identify we've now said it
can deal with time and space by wrapping
dated around things
um but this is something where what we
want to return what do you expect a
return here
I mean don't you expect might want to
know when were there military conflicts
in you know associated with Germany
this is this is asking for two things
who are the leaders in such-and-such a
time interval
but by the way them that there needn't
be any Geo about it that she's
surprising we haven't had this issue
before I mean like like what movies were
made in the 1950s so we can get that
from an entity class query right right I
wonder if this function will be at
lollipop be a convenience function for a
more complex entity class implicit and
yes I think so I think so I think it's a
good idea I mean it's it's a it's a sort
of
well I think that it's a function that
should actually resolve and it should be
able to ask what just like we can ask
with Joe identify what I mean and
there's also nearest I suppose as well
like what was the nearest you know
you're gonna want to ask that what was
the nearest war yeah I mean which war no
boy this is complicated ok so so imagine
the following case what war involve
Belgium closest to 1300
you
we cannot do with entity class I agree
well closest to I'm not sure we can't do
that with entity class um unfortunately
I have to leave basically now go go
ahead I'm sorry the entity class can
take between and that's good for dates
because you can put in beginning date
and end date right right
I have something yes continue a bit but
I have to run um so uh we should
continue this whole thing but I think
we're making really good progress here
and you should go ahead and start
implementing these things you already
discussed makes sense ok but let's set
up another meeting before we've all
forgotten how this works
and next time let's start with the notes
from this meeting um ok I have to run
sorry thanks guys right